the fate of the multiverse
depends on us
in this video we have an update
regarding a potential doctor stranger
multiverse of madness trailer going live
on wednesday so the current leak is that
apparently the upcoming trailer for
multiverse of madness will definitely
make you rush to grab your ticket as
soon as possible be prepared now i'm not
sure about the reliability about this
scooper however what we do know is that
the tickets are going to sale on
wednesday this is confirmed by marvel
themselves and normally drop it with a
trailer of some kind so i do think a
final trailer or special look for doctor
strange too is highly highly possible
for wednesday i'm not sure about what
the odds are for this so do take it with
a grain of salt but with pretty much
every marvel movie there always really
some kind of trailer for when the
tickets go on sale but in saying that
with some of the marvel films we have
we've only gotten a short teaser showing
very minimal new footage to promote the
tickets but let's say this rumor is true
and we do get a trailer tomorrow what
can we expect from this possible they
could tease a cameo from the film or
possibly we'll get a shot or sequence of
professor x which we know is confirmed
to be in the film because i do think
seeing a shot of his actual face would
get people really hyped but what do you
guys think do you think we'll get a
trailer or special look for multiverse
and miners when tickets go on sale if so
what do you think we could see from this
trailer let me know in the comment
section below and if you haven't already
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching